what's up guys
bang bang it's lunch money time well
while she's
trying to get rich the rest of us just
trying to get a lunch money right i'm
here with the beautiful intelligent
polina ivailova marinova pompliano
p-i-m-p
who looks like she about to go to the
woods and kill something today like she
may go get a deer and drag that
back skin it and eat it that's right
hunter polina is here in the house
what's up
don't forget i'm the apex predator
don't worry about it now lunch money is
sponsored by block five block five has
three products you can buy and sell
crypto on a crypto exchange you can
deposit crypto and earn up to eight
point six percent
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can use a
product where you deposit crypto and get
a us dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
end and and important new information
pay attention you can now go into your
block by account and sign up for the
wait list for the
bit block five bitcoin rewards
credit card wow that is a mouthful the
block five bitcoin rewards
credit card which means that you will
use credit you'll swipe the card rather
than get cash back or airline amounts
you'll get bitcoin back instead like
five percent i think it is
go to your blockbuy account and sign up
today blockfit.com
okay let's go okay ready don't shoot
mortgage applications to purchase a home
jumped nine percent last week from the
previous week
and we're 28 higher annually
according to the mortgage bankers
association people are buying homes
thanksgiving week isn't usually a
popular time for home buying but most
economic numbers this year are
incomparable especially in the
pandemic spiked housing market but
one important detail what the refi
mortgage applications are
down the refinement over the week yeah
refi
more of refinancing your mortgage is
down five percent but it's still up over
a hundred percent from a year ago
so what we're basically seeing here is
an explosion in mortgage interest over a
long period of time compared to the
historical
uh numbers and that is because we
have high levels of mobility we have no
rates basically low rates
uh zero interest rate environment and
when there's cheap capital and people
are moving around a lot that means that
they're going to borrow money in order
to either buy a home
or to refinance their mortgage therefore
structurally
it makes sense don't be surprised if
this only continues
and if we get in a very weird situation
where somehow
we can actually increase the housing
production
in the united states there's been a
housing shortage a lot of people don't
know this but there's about 200
000 homes short every year so
literally we're not producing enough
homes to keep up and so therefore if we
can catch up
then you're also going to get an
explosion in supply which means that you
have cheap capital high mobility and
more supply
meaning that you're likely to see home
prices drop and
mortgage applications go up maybe we
need more tiny homes
we could i mean that is one of the
solutions that people are thinking about
would you live in a tiny home
i could probably because you got your
hunter outfit on you want to go hunting
again yeah i do kind of look like a
hunter
we should admitted it okay go ahead
slack guys slack
salesforce is making the biggest
acquisition
in its 21-year history announcing that
it's officially buying
chat software developer slack for over
27 billion remember the other day when
we were like oh 23 billion market cap
27 billion is what they're buying it for
so a combination of cash in stock it's
gonna purchase it for 26.79 a share
uh okay this is this purchase marks one
of the largest
ever for the software industry the
biggest was ibm's 34 billion of
red hat in 2018. isn't red hat a raleigh
company
it was yeah i mean look this is really
really smart
uh two things that i'll immediately
mention i think i already mentioned this
one time before
if you want to own enterprise software
if you want to own the software that is
used inside of business
it's probably a good idea to own the
software that everyone is communicating
on
if you own where everyone is hanging out
and communicating on a daily basis
you probably got a good shot as to not
only monetizing them there
but also doing other things with them
inside of their organization
it's kind of crazy that slack started as
just kind of like a pet project for
stuart butterfield right like you start
well he didn't really want to build
slack
no he started he started gaming right he
started a gaming company then it like
became slack but like i don't think he
set out to
create slack no he just saw he just saw
that there was a bunch of value
in uh and users were using the that part
of the product and basically killed
everything else and then just double
down on the messaging component
i remember i used to like at my previous
jobs before slack there was hip
chat which was terrible there was um
anything called link link lync
like that i think that was like the
microsoft i don't know it was just
it's ever heard of texting yeah people
don't do that at work
i do it at work go ahead elon musk
is named business person of the year
2020 by my former employer fortune
elon it starts with is there anything
elon musk can't do the 49 year old tesla
and spacex ceo
and boring co and neural link and open
ai co-founder
has seemingly defied gravity this year
transforming his silicon valley electric
automaker into one of the world's
most valuable companies and elevating oh
my god that's a really long sentence
and elevating his los angeles aero
rocket manufacturer to new heights
including successfully sending humans
into orbit from the us
for the first time since nasa quit doing
so in 2011.
yes that was all one sentence you better
put some respect on the man's name
it's about time everyone was laughing at
him everyone was saying he was going out
of business all this nonsense
elon musk is one of the greatest
entrepreneurs to ever live
he is one of the greatest innovators to
ever live and people are going to look
back
once he is dead and be like man i wish
we had way more
of those guys he is going to be in the
conversation with the thomas edisons
with the ben franklins because what he
is doing
is unbelievable so um i read the profile
it's really good
but there's one part uh they interviewed
some of his peers and
one ceo says um you know
elon musk is most of the time
the smartest person in the room like
people will be talking he'll just sit
back
and then he'll say something and people
be like oh
because of that it can also sometimes
act as a double-edged sword
because he often thinks he is the
smartest person in the room
there is a small percentage of time when
he is not
and then you know like that gets him
into trouble
but yeah it was it was good you should
read it fortune.com
with great power comes great
responsibility and also not
not succumbing to arrogance yeah that's
fine
elon musk is doing things that the
planet and the world needs and if you're
a hater
you're losing check the scoreboard
you're losing all right go ahead
next ladder a nutritional company
founded by basketball icon lebron james
and actor arnold schwarzenegger why are
they doing business together
has been sold to technology fitness
platform openfit
openfit ceo john cognan said the tech
company purchase ladder
buying shares from investors oh so it's
like a stock deal
cool including investment from main
street advisors terms of the deal were
not
made available i love this why
because ladder for those that don't know
would have never heard of this
it's a well it's a nutrition company so
think of protein powders all that kind
of stuff but it was started but i think
it was like
um arnold schwarzenegger lebron james i
think uh maria sharapova maybe
um or lindsey vonn is that a person
that's a right
yeah i don't know there was like a whole
group of people
that uh was super legit and they all
came together like look
we constantly drink protein powders and
take vitamins do all stuff why don't we
just own the company that we use
and that's why they started ladder uh
and they ended up selling the business
financial
results were not shared but they are
staying on
with some equity uh lebron
schwarzenegger etc so my guess is that
this actually ended up being a pretty
positive deal um
but we won't know i'm sure it'll leak at
some point um
well since i drink other people's coffee
all day maybe i should start my own
coffee brand
well you'd have to wake up you see i
don't wake up because the
is not strong enough all right next i'll
create coffee so
strong no you can't even go to sleep all
right
uh man that's actually my dream if
somebody could create technology
where you could fully function and be at
your best and you didn't have to waste
eight to nine hours i love sleeping oh
my god yeah but imagine you'd be that
refreshed like you just went a little
pod
and you were like plugged me in and then
you were just ready to roll again
like sign me up for that like that is
somebody wants to build that
sign me up
okay i could do that for you with like
okay just like a little look plug me in
choo-choo all right
and then ready to roll the company that
literally started silicon valley
is moving to texas hewlett packard
traces its origins to 1938 when bill
hewlett and dave packard rented a garage
of course it's a garage in palo alto
california
now hp enterprises a descendant of the
pioneering company is moving
to texas do we know where in texas
uh i don't know where round rock okay
it's near austin
or that's dell that's dell that's down
let's tell uh oh uh oh
how does it not say where in texas i
don't know
but here's the deal everyone talking
about oh there's better talent there's
all stuff
people are moving for taxes they're
moving for taxes
by the way just say it like that's that
good if you don't say why you're moving
they'll never fix it california's taxes
are atrocious
and the city is mismanaged in san
francisco
were the taxes in california ever like
really good to attract so many companies
or were they always atrocious and people
just
accepted it because the talent was there
i think that they were always pretty
high but it's just
it's the mix between you still have
record level uh taxes
and you have literal if you walk down
san francisco i
i swear this is not me being um
bombastic
uh facetious uh uh salacious
any of that stuff you like those words
you see that command of the english
language which is
wrongly used in this scenario the people
in the comments will tell you it sounded
smart s a t word right there for all you
stay in
keep keeping notes at home if you walk
down the streets in san francisco
you literally see poop on the ground you
see syringes
might have been right high sounding but
with little meaning
inflated bombastic that's what you're
that's your essay
yeah i know but of course i have a
command of the english language
that's proper use of the word don't
worry about it but
if you think about paying really high
taxes in california and then if you live
in san francisco you walk down the
street and you really see poop on the
ground and syringes from drug addicts
and crime and you're worried about your
car getting broken into at night you
sound like my grandfather
that's what's going on it is a
free-for-all
it's like hey guys where's all the tax
money going
what are you doing with the tax money
guess what people
are voting with their feet and they're
leaving
see you voting with their feet that's
all they're doing they're just leaving
how many
people puzzle how many more people need
to leave how many more people need to
leave
either stop taking people's money or fix
the city oh my god you just destroyed it
um puzzles suck why are you playing with
it then
ask lunch money oh my god i put them in
little pies come on come on come on
ask lunch money time all right
randall fisher hey pomp was wondering
what your number one piece of advice
would be for young people that want to
break into finance in the finance
industry i'm currently
a college student i'm fascinated by
everything from just traditional
investing in the new crypto age
being that it's just a very competitive
industry what would you say is the best
way to go about finding a career
in this world do the one thing that
everyone's not willing to do which is
start doing the work before you got the
job
that's the one thing that everyone
messes up everyone wants to go to the
career fair everyone wants to get their
resume looking pretty
they want to go and worry about their
interview all that stuff you wonder how
you get a job
start doing the work and so when you
show up to the interview you say hey i
can already do the job here's all the
work
what do i mean by that you want to be an
equity analyst start analyzing equities
and putting it out
on a sub stack on the internet and
twitter threads
whatever right you want to work in
crypto cool
start writing about the analysis your
opinion whatever
put it out there show people that you
have value
and that you can do the work before you
ever even walk in for the interview
and you will have a much better
opportunity and likely what will happen
is somebody will
eventually talk to you and say hey
you're smart why don't you come work
here
they'll recruit you rather than you
showing up trying to get a job
right it's the same thing it's like when
you go and you ask people for money what
do they give you they give you advice
when you ask for advice they give you
money same thing here if you go and ask
people for a job
they tell you sorry you know you're
smart but not for us
when you walk in and say hey look i'm
smart they say you want to work here
that's the key do the job before you got
the job and also
in interviews like always come in
prepared to
critique what they're already doing and
explain how you can
add value and make it better yeah one of
my best pieces of advice for you you
want to be a salesperson
imagine if i walk into an interview and
say oh i'm a great sales person look how
smart i am
whatever or if i walk into the sales
interview and i say hey by the way
i noticed that you guys have an
enterprise software solution and that
you're going after fortune 100 companies
i have two companies that i've already
reached out to that would like to have a
discussion
who should i introduce them to
internally they're like wait a second
you showed up to the interview and you
got leads
yes you should probably just go down
yeah the last
uh desk on the right you can just sit at
that one go do whatever you just did go
get 10 more leads yeah all right next
brian hey guys love your show i don't
miss an episode every day oh
okay my question is do you guys think
bitcoin will ever be classified as a
form of currency in the u.s
thanks and be safe out there what do you
think oh definitely
agreed yeah i think they're gonna have
to do i think it's gonna be
a global larry fink the ceo of blackrock
literally the largest asset manager in
the world yesterday out loud
while talking to the former bank of
england governor mark carney
out loud the ceo and founder of the
largest asset manager in the world said
does it meet uh like
take away the importance of the us
dollars of global reserve currency it
being bitcoin
a guy who manages 7.5 trillion dollars
is asking that question out loud
wake up people next that's it that's it
okay today i gotta go do an interview i
love all of you
we'll talk to you tomorrow wow bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risks
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends